this is a japanese giant salamander  it is massive  this primeval amphibian can grow up to 5  feet long and weigh over 50 pounds  making it one of the largest salamanders  to ever crawl the face of the earth  despite its primitive look the japanese  giant salamander is highly evolved it is  covered head to tail with specialized  cells that detect tiny vibrations in its  environment  when it detects a threat it excretes a  strong smelling ooze that smells like a  japanese pepper hence its common  japanese name giant pepper fish  the japanese giant salamander is  entirely aquatic and spends its life in  clear cool flowing streams  it has no gills but instead absorbs  oxygen through its skin  if left alone the japanese giant  salamander will live a long life  this one is 26 years old and in the wild  they can live to be nearly 80.  but pollution of its river habitat and  over collection are threatening this  fascinating primordial creature  this is the japanese giant salamander